have you ever asked yourself is my phone
listening to me is my phone watching me
does my phone track me even when it's
off
maybe the real question is does it even
need to here to set the record straight
I'm David Payette former Apple Store
Tech and smartphone expert this is Tech
truths are our phones listening to us
the simple answer is yes but not in the
way you would expect if you want to rest
easy the amount of battery life our
phones would use if they listened to
everything you said all the time would
drain its battery very fast let's use
this iPhone 14 pro as an example in the
case of hey Siri the first sounds it
listens for is not hey it's it isn't
transcribing your words or entire
sentences it's not nearly powerful
enough for that instead it's listening
for a specific sequence of sounds which
is called an acoustic model the takeaway
is that your phone is absolutely
listening to you but it can only
recognize one thing hey Siri kind of
like my cats whatever I say food the
phone's main processor is a lot more
powerful than it's always on processor
but that power comes at a cost battery
life so it's the always-on processor
that always listens for trigger sounds
when the always on processor hears an S
sound it triggers a kind of built-in
checklist was the S preceded by a high
front vowel like a was it followed by
another front vowel like e if all the
boxes get checked the always on
processor wakes up the a16 bionic for
help now that the phone's main processor
is involved the possibilities for
analyzing your voice are endless of
these four companies Apple's privacy
policy for Siri is by far the clearest
and the safest at least in terms of your
personal privacy so what can you do to
protect your privacy as much as possible
if you go to the settings app on your
phone and disable hey Siri hey Google or
hi Bixby then none of this happens at
all are our phones watching us
no and they don't have to social media
companies can all infer our emotions and
our reactions based on our behavior and
what about Tick Tock they've been all
over the news lately Tick Tock collects
both face prints and voice prints from
content that you upload to their servers
doesn't sound great but it gets worse
Tick Tock uses pre-uploading to send
photos and videos from your phone to
their servers even before you choose to
share it publicly from tick tock's
privacy
we may collect biometric identifiers and
biometric information as defined under
U.S laws such as face prints and voice
prints from your user content where
required by law we will seek any
required permissions from you prior to
any such collection they'll ask our
permission to do it but only if they're
legally required to that doesn't exactly
make me feel better do our phones track
US even when they're off there's no
right or wrong answer to this one does
your phone ever really turn somebody's
door phones ever really turn all the way
off the answer to that question is no
the always-on processor stays running in
the background even when your phone's
operating system isn't but that doesn't
necessarily mean you could be tracked on
iPhones find my works even when your
phone is powered off but it's not your
phone that's tracking you all the other
Apple devices that are part of the find
my network can locate your device and
report its location to Apple servers
Androids are a different story you can
find a Samsung Galaxy phone when it's
offline meaning cellular data or Wi-Fi
are turned off but not if the phone
itself is turned all the way off
Google's find my device feature is one
step further behind that you might be
able to find your phone's last known
location but you won't be able to see
any live location if it isn't connected
to the internet if you want to not be
findable you could disable find my when
you power off your phone first press the
side button and either volume button to
slide the power off appear years on the
screen then tap the tiny text below the
slider that says iPhone findable after
power off then tap temporarily turn on
finding enter your passcode and power
off your phone alright time for Rapid
Fire Let's Go does your phone get better
service depending on how you hold it no
antenna gate is over and it's been over
since the iPhone 4. does your phone ruin
credit cards or hotel room keys your
phone by itself no it does create some
magnetic fields but they're not strong
enough to demagnetize a credit card mag
safe and other magnetic Chargers and
cases however are a different story
never put a credit card in between your
phone and a magsafe case or it will
demagnetize will it magnet wipe your
phone nope this one is a myth magnets
used to be uh oh
okay uh
do phones attract lightning no but if
you're on top of a mountain holding an
umbrella taking a selfie and you get
zapped don't blame your phone is it safe
to hold your phone while you're pumping
gas yes MythBusters already covered that
one can your phone be hacked on public
Wi-Fi or by plugging it into random usb
chargers yes but in different ways
public Wi-Fi networks are often
unsecured meaning that any device that's
also connected to it may be able to
intercept your data or see what websites
you're visiting using an attack called a
man in the middle attack plugging your
phone into public usb chargers is it a
good idea either but phone manufacturers
have been making it easier to protect
against this kind of hack the reason
public charges are so dangerous is that
your phone's charging port is also used
for data transfers you might see a
charging port but a tiny computer might
be lurking beneath the surface on
iPhones a trust this device pop-up
appears whenever you plug it into a
device that tries to access data on your
phone on Android hello
on Androids I told you on Androids the
pop-up might say something else like
enable USB file transfer that pop-up
never happens when you plug your phone
into a charger that's just a charger if
you see that kind of pop-up when you
plug in your phone don't trust it and
find another charger right away
dance
is airplane mode really necessary in
theory radio frequency interference from
cell phones could affect certain
airplane systems in practice it's not
just improbable it's likely impossible
there are a few reasons for this first
airplane systems and modern planes are
hardened against RFI there has never
been an airplane crash due to cell phone
interference I've always thought the
real reason for airplane mode wasn't
about safety it's about Wireless
carriers as we travel our cell phones
get handed off from Tower to Tower to
Tower if you have airplanes full of
hundreds of phones zipping by these
towers at hundreds of miles an hour
that's a lot of handing off for cell
phone carriers to do the European Union
recently made the decision to allow 5G
on their planes along with previous
mobile technology Generations like 4G
so this means airplane mode is about to
become a thing of the past at least in
the EU what about flights in the U.S you
ask not a peep from the FAA so far
airplane mode isn't going anywhere yet
does dark mode actually help your
eyesight I'm not a doctor but my opinion
is yes in certain circumstances and
especially since OLED displays became
mainstream maybe you're thinking okay
nerd why is OLED or organic light
emitting diode such a big deal
it's easiest if I show you both these
phones are showing an image of some
white text on a black background but one
of the backgrounds isn't really black is
it it's more of a glowing blue the big
deal with OLED is that instead of your
phone's backlight lighting up the entire
screen now the black pixels are just off
not only does it increase contrast and
make your phone easier to look at no
backlight means longer battery life dark
mode on OLED displays helps your
eyesight more the dark mode on older LCD
screens is planned obsolescence real I
think so but tech companies are sneaky
about it today's phones have amazingly
powerful Hardware but one of the things
people complain about is that once we
upgrade our phones to the latest version
of the operating system we can never go
back to an older one and the result is
that over time new features mean our
phones get slower usually iPhones
support about five years of the latest
versions of iOS for instance iOS 16
which came out in September 2022 is
reported on phones as old as the iPhone
10 and the iPhone 8. both of which were
released in 2017. Androids however are a
different story whether or not you could
downgrade the software on your Android
phone depends entirely on the phone
manufacturer and model of phone you have
whether or not you should downgrade your
Android is a different story you could
expose your phone to a software
vulnerability that had been patched or
void your warranty so how often should
we be updating our phones my advice is
to always update to the latest version
of the operating system unless your
phone is the oldest model supported by
the newest operating system how
waterproof are our phones really
basically phones are about as water
resistant as they need to be Apple and
Samsung love to talk about various
phones IP ratings an English protection
rating is composed of two digits the
first digit which could be zero through
six represents the degree of protection
against solids like dust and dirt the
second number which could be 0 0-9
represents a phone's degree of
protection against liquids IP67 is
clearly defined you can have your phone
underwater for 30 minutes at up to one
meter deep or it's about three feet and
ip68 can mean very different things for
different phones but they're all rated
ip68 what about ip69 readings do we need
that not unless you're power washing
your phone but there's a catch our
phones are water resistant not soapy
water resistant over time exposure to
other liquids can slowly break down the
waterproof seals inside your phone so be
careful the next time you're in the
shower shampoo your hair but not your
phone this closing apps really enhance
your phone's performance I think we can
all agree that the science performance
has gone downhill but we might not all
agree on my response to this question
companies like Apple and Samsung put a
lot of effort into building an operating
system that manages memory very
efficiently and minimizes the amount of
Battery apps used when they're not on
the screen that is absolutely true the
second point they make is that you're
actually wasting phone battery life if
you close out your apps because it takes
more battery to start an app up from
scratch than it does to restore it from
the background sleep state that is also
true but there's one very important and
fairly obvious thing the expert it's
often leave out apps don't always do
what they're supposed to otherwise why
would Apple have an article about what
to do with unresponsive apps when
something goes wrong with an app and it
happens a lot it can rev your phone's
processor all the way up to 100 and get
stuck there and that drains your battery
life my opinion is that it's a good idea
to close out your apps at the end of the
day
just to be safe
or whenever you notice your phone
battery draining faster or getting
hotter than normal what's the deal with
exploding phone batteries inside every
phone repair shop there's one very
important very low-tech piece of
technology a fire safe or at least there
should be
every new technician is told that if a
phone battery starts to leak or Sizzle
or smoke to throw it in the fire safe
and shut the door Lithium-ion batteries
don't usually explode at least not in
the traditional sense when they're
damaged or they're short circuit the
chemicals inside react poorly they smoke
or they bubble and sometimes they do
catch on fire usually though there are
warning signs phones rarely go up in
Flames but if no one's around to notice
the problem that's where the real danger
occurs and that's why it's not the best
idea to put Lithium-ion batteries in
your checked baggage on an airplane if
your phone is so hot it feels like it's
going to catch on fire turn it off if
you can and then set it aside until it
cools down what's the best way to charge
our phones Lithium-ion batteries are
much smarter than older nickel cadmium
or nickel metal hydride rechargeable
batteries the smart technology built
into our phones is designed to help
maximize the battery's lifespan the zero
to 100 charge level you see on your
phone doesn't represent the battery's
actual minimum or maximum capacity it's
kind of like the gas gauge on your car
you can fill it up past F and when you
hit e there's still a little bit of gas
left in the tank 100 of your phone is
the maximum capacity it can be charged
to without over charging which could
damage the battery on the other hand
zero percent is the minimum amount of
charge your phone could be recharged
from with lithium ion batteries if they
run completely out of juice they never
work again if you're going to store your
phone for a long period of time leave it
charged to around 50 percent to maximize
its lifespan how often should you turn
off your phone I like to say once a week
not only will it help you maximize your
phone's performance it'll also help you
save some battery life
um
hi Mr cable
how often do you really need to clean
your phone's screen according to Charles
Gerber a microbiologist at the
University of Arizona cell phones have
about 10 times as many bacteria as the
average toilet seat incidentally toilet
seats aren't really even that bad
it's those remote control
it's those remote controls and doorknobs
you need to watch out for scientists say
it's not our germs that get us sick it's
other people's germs so I think the
answer to how often you should clean
your phone depends on how often you're
handing it to other people if you're
going to visit your grandparents to show
them photos it might be a good idea to
sanitize your phone first well we may
never know everything going on behind
the scenes of the world of tech with a
little digging there's a lot of
intriguing and alarming information to
discover until next time I'm David
Payette and this was Texas